[Applause]
[Music]
Hong Kong is one of those places that
probably need no introduction because
you already know all about it situated
in the south of China Hong Kong is a
lively bustling city with a great deal
of contrast in Hong Kong it isn't
surprising to see ancient lorries
running alongside luxury cars you'll
also see ruins buildings right next to
fancy modern skyscrapers and you'll see
top-notch restaurants next to street
food cars laughter they all do have one
thing in common they occupy tiny spaces
this is true whether the location is a
high-end mall or just a traditional
storefront whatever business you operate
in Hong Kong the most is made of every
single square metre
now Hong Kong was one of the biggest
miracles of the 20th century in fact it
was the model Milton Friedman himself
looks at in order to prove his pro
free-trade thesis if you want to see how
the free market really works that's just
a place to come after World War 2 Hong
Kong's population was around 600,000
people it had an income equivalent to
about a quarter of the United Kingdom
sixty years later and the population now
exceeds 7 million people and the per
capita income is almost equal to the UK
when purchasing power is considered in
the GDP is much larger than the one in
the UK
[Music]
over the last 60 years Hong Kong has not
only become the fourth most significant
financial center in the world and one of
the 10 most important markets but it has
also become a shelter for millions of
Chinese citizens to escape to the
poverty and violence of Mao's China with
all the Economic Development economic
freedom is something that you can really
feel in the air in Hong Kong now Hong
Kong cannot exactly be considered a free
paradise but nowadays it can be
considered the freest economy in the
world and the fourth easiest place to do
business in the world anyway the key to
Hong Kong's economic development is
going to be discussed in a future video
but today we're going to focus on the
politics of Hong Kong and the threats
against its institutional structure
which might even compromise its future
economic development and to do so we're
gonna have to start by looking at the
great paradox that China is facing the
paradox which has become something of a
hallmark to the country
Hong Kong was a British colony until
1997 when the city integrated into China
again something that hadn't happened
since the 19th century China was and
today remains a dictatorship
lacking respect for human right and
having very few civil liberties this
forced the governments in London and
Beijing to negotiate a solution the
citizens of Hong Kong didn't want to
lose their fundamental rights and London
simply couldn't tolerate the Chinese
applying their authoritarian model for
the city after long negotiation in 1984
they reached an agreement known as the
sino-british joint declaration which
established that for 50 years after the
integration Hong Kong would have a
different political system than the one
in mainland China this meant that after
1997 Hong Kong became a special
administrative region where these
so-called basic law applies this is a
law that granted citizens rights and
freedoms that would be unimaginable in
any other place in China with the
exception of Macau which was integrated
into China following the same model the
citizens in Hong Kong has freedom of
speech freedom of the press freedom of
publication freedom of assembly and
Association and even freedom of
demonstration further Hong Kong has its
own currency its own immigration policy
customs policy its own police and even
has its own course so at first things
went really well following this policy
and the economic growth we mentioned
earlier certainly did help the citizens
kept their own free status they could
apply their own policies and Hong Kong
became the natural entrance for foreign
investments into China
however after a few years things started
to get rather worse the rating law we
mentioned a moment ago acknowledges
civil rights but not civil democracy in
fact China has control over the
Parliament and the city's executive
power so how did they do this well first
in Hong Kong only half of the MPs are
chosen through the popular vote the
other half are chosen by a closed group
formed of entrepreneurs and institutions
close to China
now why Ching and Baggio Leung are
separatists arguing for independence
from China they were excluded from the
chamber for using offensive language
then there is the head of the executive
branch and that's the prime minister who
is chosen by a committee of 1,200 people
involved or linked in one way or another
to the Communist Party in addition to
that all public officials must take an
oath of allegiance and commitments to
China because of this there's an
argument to be made that some of these
positions are actually in legitimate
finally the basic law states that the
autonomy of Hong Kong is subordinate to
the Chinese People's Congress
[Music]
Special Administrative Region of the
people to [ __ ] off seen that however
the treaty demanded that from 2017 the
executive chief had to be chosen by
popular vote and this leads us to the
part of the story where China started to
break their word over and over again on
the 31st of August 2014 the National
Congress in Beijing started the
electoral reform which would choose the
government chief in this special region
and here was the surprise yes Beijing
did acknowledge that this should be
chosen by popular folks but they could
only choose between two or three
candidates who had been previously
selected by the Communist Party yes some
surprisingly the Chinese do have a
rather different idea of democracy so
over the next few days the people really
started rising up first these were
protests led by students some of them as
young as 17 years old how can you
explain to a young educated student who
grew up with full access to the Internet
and the media that they are actually
going to have to live under a Chinese
dictatorship after all in 2017 I believe
there were more demonstrations and
protests especially under the interface
of Beijing government
it's just proved the failure of one
country two systems' the reaction of the
authorities to these first strikes and
mobilizations wasn't very friendly they
decided to use force but the result was
the opposite of what they were expecting
instead of containing the protests more
and more people took to the streets
moved by the fear of having to remain
under the rule of Beijing in a short
time a huge demonstration developed in
the centre of Hong Kong headed by the
organization's occupy central and
scholarism not only me all last year
won't go home until we are wake 3 at
last the police started using tear gas
and pepper spray to control the
protesters and the population started
using towels masks and umbrellas to
mitigate the effect of the gas for this
reason the protests actually became
known as the umbrella revolution
the occupation of Central Hong Kong
lasted for 79 days and since then the
conflict has continued with some
spontaneous outbreaks and young people
getting more radical and not just
demanding democracy for demanding
independence from China this is
something by the way that China has said
that they absolutely will not tolerate
under any circumstances even if they
have to use military force as an
interesting a cited by the way China has
recently kidnapped five librarians in
Hong Kong for spreading ideas against
China's control of the city I was
visiting my girlfriend in the mainland
and I was stopped by two officials at
the border they took me to a police fan
where there were dozens of policemen
waiting up then I was taken to the
police station in Shenzhen where I was
held in the prisoners compound and
interrogated largely because of these
protests the September 2016 elections
were celebrated and many of the protest
leaders were chosen as MPs their anti
Beijing pro-independence positions have
opened up the conflict door again since
September two MPs have already been
expelled from their offices under
pressure from mainland China
[Applause]
[Music]
and as I mentioned earlier in this video
civil rights are only protected in Hong
Kong until 2047 and it seems that every
day China's involvement in the city
grows and grows and this does come with
a price
potential investors in China through
Hong Kong are starting to perceive a
risk this is probably one of the reasons
why Singapore has experienced such
strong growth in the last few years so
that's what we think but what do you
think using the citizens in Hong Kong
should fight for their freedom do you
think China will eventually completely
control Hong Kong do let us know in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you and if you like this video do click
that like button below and if you
haven't done so yet please do subscribe
to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you